we've always attempted to create
benchmark visuals for PlayStation we
wanted to do this but then with an
open-world game so one of the visions
for this game was to do kind of a planet
Earth BBC nature documentary style game
we really had to improve the engine to
be capable of rendering these very big
open landscapes if you're just exploring
the world and running around sprinting
going into the underground places
there's never a loading screen it's all
signals this place I haven't been here
in years so that's what that guys have
been working on very hard there's danger
ahead girl danger for you Outlander this
is Norland in current day games facial
animation and RPGs is an ascetic of the
highest quality and we felt like it was
clearly an area that that we could put
some effort into improving we have so
much interactive dialogue that the
characters that your encounter need to
look very good on many levels
traditionally people use procedural
automation where they do a lot of mouth
flapping that gets generated on by the
sound we decided to mocap almost 15
hours of dialogue that we have in the
game and see if we can do it at a higher
quality for ourselves we made a gigantic
leap there in the quality of facial
animation and the believability of the
characters in the world
please do